[Music]
william reed was the jackie robinson of
hockey the first black black player in
the nhl here he is at 22 years old in
the 1950s the late 1950s as a rookie
forward for the boston bruins since then
he's continued to be a powerful
influence on the sport promoting hockey
and minority communities now his
contributions are being recognized in
boston and on capitol hill major garrett
spoke with ore and shares his remarkable
story
boston went oh re down the ice willie
o'reilly became the first black player
in the national hockey league in 1958
suiting up for the boston bruins and
it's 3-1 o'ree now 86 was playing minor
league hockey in quebec when he got the
call on january the 18th 1958
the bruins called the quebec case and
says we want to re
to meet the bruins in montreal to play
two games against montreal canadians oh
reid did what jackie robinson had done
11 years earlier integrate a white sport
as a black professional they sat me down
and said willie we brought you up
because we think you can add a little
something to the club don't worry about
anything else about just going out and
playing your game the speedy winger did
and afterward described it this way it
was the greatest sound of my life i
believe i'll always remember this day
i'm going to ask you a question i i
think in the first period you look like
you're a little nervous were you yes i
bet it scared you a little yes it did oh
ree was talking about achieving his
ultimate goal playing in the nhl not
making racial history i didn't recognize
that i i had broke the colorbar until i
read it in the paper the next day
did you encounter any racial hostility
oh yeah you know from uh from different
players and fans in the stand different
players on yeah on the opposition yeah i
heard the racial remarks and um racial
slurs and it was in chicago and new york
uh probably the the worst problems i had
black players in pro sports knew what to
expect and were expected to endure it
in silence in terms of this business of
being the jackie robinson of hockey have
you had any troubles
no none none that you could uh say that
were troubles i've heard a few jeers
like that but i guess all hockey players
yeah antoree goes back for boston o'ree
played 45 games in the nhl over two
seasons then flourished in minor league
hockey winning two scoring titles i
remember the first time i came into this
building in san diego where o'ree played
eight seasons his number is the only one
in the rafters next week are we getting
set the boston bruins will retire oree's
number 22. i'm over overwhelmed and
really really excited but kelly i'm
i'm really thrilled o'ree is already in
the hockey hall of fame he has a statue
at the national museum of african
american history and culture and he is
on the verge of receiving the
congressional gold medal he really is
somebody that exemplifies courage and
you know what we want as a role model
for our kids senator debbie stabenow of
michigan and congressman mike quigley of
illinois have led the gold medal effort
congress's highest civilian award when
you started talking to your colleagues
did any of them know who willie was no
how about you mike very very few knew
who he was i'll be honest
i grew up not knowing who willie was was
it a hard sell once you had the
conversation no in fact people would go
the first black player
and the nhl wow and when he went to the
chicago stadium as a boston bruin the
fans were the worst in the league and so
were the players it's tough to hear
because these were my heroes growing up
this story it has a twist i had an
unfortunate accident willie o'reilly the
nhl's first black player a descendant of
slaves played his entire professional
career
blind in his right eye it was a slap
shot from the point the [ __ ] him up and
hit me flat in the right eye and broke
broke my nose o-rie surgeon said he'd
never play hockey again but within weeks
he was back on the ice striving for the
nhl he swore his family to secrecy and
never told any team of his blindness i
said forget about what you can't see and
just concentrate on what you can see
what he couldn't see then was the
enduring power of his example you can
only imagine what he's been through
anthony declare plays forward for the
florida panthers i was a young black
male playing hockey in a predominantly
white sport
you know you don't see too many black
athletes therefore you motivated me i
would say to make the nhl and try to you
know pass it on forward to the next
generation for sure uri has spent the
last 25 years passing it forward to the
next generation as one of the nhl's
diversity ambassadors bringing hockey to
underserved minority communities this is
what i tell these kids you can do
anything you set your mind to do and
don't let anybody tell you you can't
attain your goal if you feel strongly
within your heart and within your mind
and never give up
willie did some of that outreach right
here at fort dupont ice rink in
washington dc william reid is quite
obviously a national hero he's also a
personal hero of mine i grew up watching
him play for the san diego goals as a
child in san diego william inspired me
to pick up the sport and we have some
photographic evidence of that there you
see it yours truly age 14 fully suited
up san diego skyline in the background
to meet william with one of the great
privileges of my life and an honor as a
hockey player a san diegan and an
american gayle
wow yours truly still looking pretty
good there major you look fantastic and
look good on that nice thing yeah
don't go anywhere but i want to go back
to willie o'ree and then i want to go
back to major's picture number one brian
mullen who knows the thing about hockey
in our studio has been talking about
willie o'reilly for years
but it's something about when you see
all of the things that he went through
did in that interview he seemed to
downplay the racism that he experienced
and now now he's talking about it major
which i also think is very happy very
healthy and very important to do imagine
what this man went through and was blind
on in one eye that's extraordinary
exactly the blindness is one aspect of
the story but all the racial slurs and
hostility he encountered he knew he
simply had to endure it that was the
only option it was the only option for
jackie robinson it was the only option
for willie o'ree and he really didn't
ever talk about it then he's not so
comfortable talking about it now he will
recognize it acknowledge it but say i
push through it and i tell children from
minority communities don't worry about
it pursue your dreams
work hard believe in your heart that you
can achieve things and all things are
possible
and major can i say you look really good
on skates but i'm so glad you got the
skills yes you still got skills you got
skills
and you were so cute i played as a child
very cute
it's still very plain
so
so that rink in san diego willie's pla
played there i played there he skated on
this rank i've skated on this ring so
it's all together very cool